Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich brauche mal kurz dein Handy, gib mal PIN.
Die errätst du nie.
Ich probiere mal 0000.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 271, frisch vom 12. Oktober 2018, jetzt neue Kinoos.
Entschuldigung, kann ich hier mal ganz kurz auf den Tisch steigen und eine Keynote halten?
Make Logbuch-Netzpolitik great again.
Tim, wir könnten ein wasserstoffbetriebenes Flugzeug kaufen.
Wirklich? Flugtaxi.
Wasserstoffbetriebenes Flugtaxi.
Das macht die Nacht zum Tage das wird auch noch kommen ja man kann zu dem Wahnsinn
der sich in USA abspielt eigentlich fast nichts mehr sagen das ist alles nur
noch hochgradig deprimierend ich würde sagen wir konzentrieren uns auf die deprimierenden
Aspekte Europas das trägt ja schon weit genug,
ja ansonsten bist du erholt und alles gut ja alles super ne schön dann machen
wir jetzt weiter sozusagen Ja,
fangen wir doch mal kurz an mit Feedback. Da war jetzt gar nicht so viel.
In der letzten Sendung hatte ich mit Thomas ein bisschen rumgescherzt,
warum es denn so wenig Nobelpreise gibt für Informatiker.
Wurde ich natürlich gleich darauf hingewiesen, gibt es alles schon.
Für den Mathematiker gibt es halt keinen Nobelpreis, aber die Fields-Medaille.
Und für die Informatiker gibt es auch keinen Nobelpreis, aber den Turing Award.
Und das sei ja alles äquivalent.
Gut, keine Ahnung, ob ich das schon mal in meinem Leben gehört habe.
Ich habe es auf jeden Fall ausreichend verdrängt gehabt.
Dem sei jetzt hier nochmal Richtung getragen und das erwiesen.
Wer hat den denn so in letzter Zeit bekommen? Diffie. Whitfield Diffie hat den
2015 bekommen. Tim Berners Lied 2016.
Das waren dann aber auch schon die bekannteren Personen. Der Rest sind wirklich
eher so Leute, die wahrscheinlich noch nie das Büro verlassen haben.
Ähm, ja, so für so Dinge.
Gibt's einen Deutschen? Nee, also größtenteils Amerikaner.
Israeli, Norweger sehe ich noch.
Ja.
Ja, also gibt's auch hier natürlich, das wurde, ah, Wind & Surf 2004.
Niklaus Wirth, Dennis Ritchie, Ken Thompson. Also schon so ein paar Leute dabei,
die man auch kennt. Alles gut.
Ja, sehr schön. So, wann kriegen wir den? Nächstes Jahr.
Nächstes Jahr. Irgendwann kriegen wir ein Podcast-Award.
Für die Podcast-Chapter-Marx, Podlove-Chapter-Marx, den Print-Love-Live-Type.
Es würde glaube ich auch nochmal erwähnt, dass so etwas gibt es eben für,
Durchbrüche in der Informatik und die sind eben häufiger,
eher in theoretischer Natur, also Grundlagenforschung, als jetzt irgendwie das
Zuckerberg den bekommen würde, weil er ein Facebook geschrieben hat.
Ja, das war ja auch nur ein Witz.
Kann man ja trotzdem mal erklären.
Kann man mal erklären. Auch ein guter Witz ist das, was so die Tories da in
Britannien gerade abziehen.
Kriegen sie auch kein Touring-Award für, ne?
Ne. Das kam jetzt hier, ich weiß nicht, wer hat uns darauf hingewiesen,
das kam per Twitter reingerauscht oder so, ne?
Ne, per E-Mail, per E-Mail.
Genau. Genau, ein Hinweis ist vielleicht nochmal der Erwähnung wert.
Also man hat ja heutzutage Apps.
So auch die Tories, also die konservative Partei Großbritanniens,
und als guter Tory lädt man sich dann halt die App runter namens Conservative Campaigner,
CC und ja da
kann man dann sich dann irgendwie anmelden und dann kann man dann sich alerten
lassen irgendwelche Campaigns und Action Call to Action folgen und pipapo und
tolle Sachen machen und Action Points sammeln und kriegt Bonuspunkte und wird
also die ganze Zeit so geziesst irgendwie Dinge zu tun Brexit-Gamification.
Genau, Brexit-Gamification und das nicht nur, weil es jetzt hier um die Tories geht,
sondern weil diese Software letzten Endes nichts anderes ist als die YouCampaign-App,
die am laufenden Meter für bestimmte Kampagnen immer wieder neu verwendet wird.
Aus der Finanzierungsquelle von Robert Mercer, einem Billionär,
der ja auch schon bei dieser ganzen Cambridge Analytica-Geschichte dahinter stand.
Und es ist auch wenig überraschend, wenn man feststellt, wo das alles noch zum Einsatz kam.
Zum Beispiel beim irischen Referendum gegen Abtreibung, was gescheitert ist,
gab es gleich zwei Apps auf der Basis, die Vote Leave App beim Brexit,
Die Trump-Pence-App, NRA,
Republikanischer Nationalkongress, R&C, Ted Cruz, also alles,
was irgendwie einen schlechten Ruf hat auf diesem Planeten, versammelt sich hinter dieser App.
Jetzt eben auch die Tories. Wenn man da irgendwie mit arbeitet,
gibt es sehr wenige Privatsphären-Deklarationen.
Da wird dann irgendwie mit Facebook Analytics, Facebook Login,
Facebook Share und Google Firebase Analytics gleich vier fette Tracker eingesetzt,
die also genau messen, was man da eigentlich mit dieser App so macht.
Davon abgesehen, dass sie halt auch ganz gerne mal auf die eigenen Kontakte zugreift.
Mittlerweile leitet sie wohl nicht gleich das ganze Adressbuch hoch,
aber frühere Version dieser App haben das sehr wohl gemacht und das dann natürlich
mit entsprechenden Wählerlisten abgeglichen. Also,
Bin ich überraschend.
Läuft es da nicht so gut. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass da mal Leute,
Freunde der GDPR, also der Datenschutzregelung jetzt da mal ordentlich beigehen.
Da werden die Briten sich aber freuen, wenn sie jetzt noch ein GDPR-Verfahren kriegen.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich, das interessiert die dann irgendwie auch nicht
mehr. Die sind nämlich sehr beschäftigt mit Brexit.
Wie heißt die Insel? Das Ferienparadies? Was jetzt bald verhungern muss?
Angela.
Angela. Angela muss verhungern.
Ja, mit dem Brexit, vielleicht sage ich noch mal ein paar Worte dazu.
So previously on Brexit.
Die letzten beiden Updates kamen ja hier ganz gut an, deswegen dachte ich mir,
da ich sonst kein Outlet dafür habe und ich mich in letzter Zeit noch mehr mit
dem ganzen Wahnsinn beschäftigt habe, als ich es ohnehin schon getan habe.
Vielleicht mal so einen kurzen Einblick, was eigentlich gerade abgeht.
Und ich finde es irgendwie interessant, dass das Thema immer noch nicht,
es ist immer noch nicht das Nummer 1 Thema, aber wir sind glaube ich ganz kurz
davor, dass es alles verdrängt, denn jetzt tickt die Uhr nicht nur, jetzt läuft sie ab.
Nächste Woche muss eigentlich eine Einigung erzielt werden, wie denn dieses
Austrittsabkommen nun aussehen soll.
Und zur Erinnerung, alle reden ja von dem zukünftigen Verhältnis,
was die EU und Großbritannien haben können und sollten.
Das Ding ist, da sind wir eigentlich noch gar nicht, weil die Briten immer noch
nicht das erfüllt haben, was die EU gesagt hat, was erstmal erfüllt sein muss.
Es gibt nämlich immer noch kein Austrittsabkommen.
Also das, worüber seit zwei Jahren geredet wird, ist sozusagen eigentlich noch nicht weit gediehen.
Ich dachte, das wäre dann auch Teil, das Austrittsabkommen würde regeln,
wie die sich denn dann nachher vertragen oder nicht?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Das Austrittsabkommen sagt einfach erstmal nur,
was die Bedingungen des Austritts sind.
Wozu sich quasi Großbritannien verpflichtet.
Ja.
Da fließt dann mit ein, wie viel Kohle
die EU noch bekommt, weil sich ja Großbritannien lange Zeit, also UK,
auf mehrere Jahre ja committed hat, an bestimmten Programmen teilzunehmen,
die alle aufgesetzt wurden und wo ja mit dem Funding von UK auch das Ganze gerechnet
wurde und die anderen sehen nicht ein, dass sie das jetzt bezahlen sollen.
Ja.
Da ist so die Zahl von 39 Milliarden Euro im Raum, wo dann auch gerne von den
Brexiteers immer gedroht wird, ja nö, zahlen wir nicht und so, was für...
Fällt euch überhaupt ein und ihr seid ja alle doof und riecht nach Lulu.
Dann ist die Garantie der Rechte der EU-Bürger in Großbritannien als auch die
Rechte der Briten in der EU etwas, worum sich die EU kümmert.
Großbritannien eher weniger, lustigerweise. Da weiß ich nicht so ganz genau,
wie jetzt die Details aussehen, aber im Wesentlichen hat sich da auch die EU
durchgesetzt und gesagt, so, die lasst ja mal jetzt mal in Ruhe.
Die werden also jetzt nicht gleich rausgeschmissen. etc.
Mit irgendwelchen Fristen wird das verbandelt sein und dritter Punkt,
ganz wichtig, die Nordirland-Frage.
Und das Ding ist, und das ist glaube ich wenigen klar, diese Nordirland-Frage.
Ungelöst. Immer noch. Und zwar komplett perspektivlos ungelöst.
Was ist die Nordirland-Frage? Nordirland ist ja Teil der Insel Irland.
Teilt sich also mit der Republik Irland einen Raum. Und es gibt halt derzeit da keine Grenze.
Man fährt da halt hin und her und macht Trade und so weiter,
weil es ist ja irgendwie alles ein Wirtschaftsbereich.
Und Irland besteht da drauf und die EU besteht da drauf und eigentlich besteht
auch Großbritannien darauf, also UK darauf, dass das auch so bleibt.
Das Ding ist nur, wenn Großbritannien jetzt die EU verlässt und alle Verträge absagt.
Dann muss Irland eine Grenze hochziehen.
Dann muss man eigentlich eine Grenze aufziehen, weil das die WTO-Regeln so besagen.
Du musst dann deine Außengrenze entsprechend absichern.
Und das will aber niemand. Und selbst wenn es jemand wollen würde und tun würde
und da irgendwelche Polizisten irgendwo hinstellt.
Was sowieso komplett illusorisch ist, weil es gibt allein zwischen Nordirland
und Irland gibt es irgendwie sowas in der Größenordnung von 200 und ein paar
offizielle Grenzübergänge.
Der Trump könnte da doch eine Mauer hinbauen einfach.
Ja, viel Spaß. 200 Grenzübergänge.
Zum Vergleich die komplette Ostgrenze der EU gegenüber Weißrussland und so weiter.
Und Russland hat so 100, die auch aktiv bestückt sind, aber der Aufwand wäre
gar nicht zu leisten und selbst wenn man das machen würde, würden wahrscheinlich
die Leute, die dann da stehen, die armen Säue,
erschossen werden von den Leuten, die nur darauf warten,
in Nordirland wieder Rambazamba zu machen, denn das Ganze wird eigentlich dadurch
verhindert und diese Hauptbedingung ist ja quasi die Erfüllung des Karfreitagsabkommens,
also des Friedensvertrags für Nordirland.
Jetzt haben wir aber leider das Problem, dass die Tories nicht alleine regieren,
sondern ja in einer Koalition sind, weil sie ja dummerweise die May eine neue
Wahl angestoßen hat, die sie dann verloren hat und nur noch in einer Koalition
mit der DUP regieren kann.
Die DUP, das sind so die Unionisten, also die Großbritannien,
UK, Queen-treuen Briten in Nordirland, die unbedingt Teil von UK bleiben wollen.
Außerdem sind sie vollkommen schwachmaten gegen Abtreibung und alles mögliche
und haben dann quasi qua ihres Koalitionsanteils eine andere Regelung durchgesetzt
in den internen Beschlüssen der Tories, ist,
dass ja auch zwischen Nordirland und UK keine solche Zollgrenze entstehen darf.
Weil, wo kommt man denn da hin? Dann werden wir ja abgekoppelt,
dann werden wir ja Teil von Irland.
Und die haben natürlich total Angst, dass irgendwie so eine Reunification da
wieder angestoßen wird.
Nun, das Problem ist, entweder hast du sie auf der einen Seite oder du hast
sie auf der anderen. Also es schließt sich alles komplett aus.
Sprich, UK und dieser ganze Brexit ist ein einziger Deadlock und nichts geht voran.
Es gibt ja theoretisch vier Szenarien, mit denen man jetzt irgendwie arbeiten könnte.
Es gibt das Szenario Hard Brexit, was so eigentlich die Brexitiers so wollen.
Ja, wir treten mal überall aus, aber irgendwie haben wir noch so ein bisschen Verbindung.
Problem ist, das will irgendwie auch von den Tories keiner und von den Labour keiner.
Es gibt viel zu viel Widerstand, insbesondere in dem House of Lords,
also in der zweiten Kammer des Parlaments. Ist irgendwie unmöglich.
Soft-Brexit ist so, naja, wir treten zwar mal aus, aber wir machen trotzdem überall noch mit.
So ein Norwegen-Modell und so eine Sachen. Das wollen dann die Hard-Brexit-Tiers
nicht. Gibt es auch keine Mehrheit für.
Also gibt es sozusagen für gar keine richtige Brexit-Lösung irgendwas.
Bleibt dann eben dieses, wir können uns auf gar nichts einigen.
Es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Deal. Das sogenannte No-Deal-Szenario. Das würde zu einer...
Das ist eine Vollkatastrophe, das würde, sagen wir mal, sofort zu brennenden
Mülltonnen und sehr viel mehr Schaden führen.
Und die vierte Option ist halt, sorry, war alles nur ein Witz,
wir blasen das jetzt mal ab, können wir nicht doch in der EU bleiben.
Und die will auch keiner. Naja, also die Bevölkerung ist da mittlerweile eigentlich
ganz anders aufgestellt.
Also die Umfragen, die letzten sagen eigentlich alle Mehrheit für Remain.
Mittlerweile bereuen es einfach so viele Leute, Leaf gewählt zu haben oder nicht
gewählt zu haben, dass nahezu überall es eine Mehrheit gibt für Remain.
Nur das Durchsetzen eines zweiten Referendums ist halt nicht im Interesse des
Establishments und deswegen wehren die sich damit Händen und Füßen.
Leider gibt es auch keine starke Opposition, weil Labour irgendwie,
naja, so People's Vote, das könnte man ja vielleicht mal machen,
aber eigentlich hätten wir lieber Neuwahlen, weil wir wollen ja an die Macht.
Das wiederum macht die Tories totale Angst, weil halt dieser Corbyn so ein hardcore
kommunistisch angehauchter Erzlinker ist, wo halt alle irgendwie schon Untergang
des Abendlandes bevorsehen.
Obwohl sie eigentlich selber gerade am Untergang ihres Abendlandes arbeiten.
Das ist so mal knapp gesagt das Szenario, in dem wir uns gerade befinden und
keiner weiß einfach vor und keiner weiß zurück.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was so der geheime Plan ist.
Auf jeden Fall ist der Weg, den die EU gerade geht, ziemlich krass,
weil sie eigentlich pokern.
Sie bleiben ja knallhart bei ihrer Meinung und mit ihrer Position haben eigentlich
UK keine andere Möglichkeit, als zu kapitulieren. Jetzt sind die natürlich recht
stolz unterwegs und so kapitulieren, weiß ja, Ruhe, Britannia, macht der Brite nicht.
Also die EU setzt jetzt eigentlich da drauf mit ihrer harten Position.
So viel Panik zu erzeugen, dass im Land irgendwas kippt, damit es noch ein Referendum
gibt, damit am Ende doch wieder für ein Remain-Programm gestimmt wird,
was die EU ja dann wahrscheinlich happily akzeptieren würde.
Also ich würde sagen, ja okay, da ist schwierig, kostet euch ein bisschen was,
hier Rabatte könnt ihr vergessen, aber wir nehmen euch wieder auf.
So und dann vergessen wir das auch.
Das wäre natürlich das Optimale. Großbritannien würde so oder so verlieren, das ist ganz klar.
Also zu gewinnen gibt es für die jetzt eigentlich gar nichts mehr.
Dann gibt es aber auch so andere Verschwörungstheorien und Tweets,
die sagen, naja, die Brexiteers, die sind mittlerweile so hardcore unterwegs und Russen gesponsert,
dass sie es geradezu darauf anlegen,
so ein No-Deal-Szenario zu erzeugen, um dann einfach in dem Chaos einen Umsturz zu machen.
Also das ist so die die Breite und wie sehr die Panik da jetzt auch wirklich
schon um sich greift zeigt sich unter anderem daran,
dass es jetzt im Vereinigten Königreich gibt es jetzt einen neuen Ministerposten
nämlich den Minister of Food,
also sie haben jetzt ein Ministerium eingesetzt was sich nicht um Verbraucherschutz
oder sowas kümmert sondern dass es überhaupt was zu essen gibt Das hatten sie
schon mal, nämlich kurz nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
So, also das ist so der Level, auf dem sich das gerade befindet.
Parallel dazu wird die Industrie langsam panisch, kündigt am laufenden Meter
Schließungen, temporäre dauerhafte Schließungen, Verlagerungen von Unternehmen an.
Und der Agrarsektor geht auch steil, weil sie jetzt irgendwie nach zwei Jahren
gemerkt haben, dass sie ja eigentlich nur leben, weil sie durch EU-Recht beschützt
sind und vor allem durch die starke Agrarförderung am Leben erhalten werden.
Und dass in dem Moment, wo halt so ein No-Deal-Szenario eintritt,
im Prinzip alle Grenzen geöffnet werden müssen für Essen von außen und dann
werden sie natürlich in 0,0x überschwemmt mit Nahrungsmitteln aus den USA und anderen Quellen.
Und können sich da herzlich wenig dagegen wehren.
Und dann wäre es halt auch vorbei mit dem Agrarsektor innerhalb von zwei Wochen,
wie so allgemein eingeschätzt wird.
Das Ganze ist ein ganz dickes Teil und ich bin gespannt, wie sehr uns das noch um die Ohren fliegt.
Wer Lust hat, sich da ein bisschen reinzulesen und zu hören,
ich habe nochmal ein Video verlinkt, was gerade so die Position der EU-Staaten
auch nochmal genauer erklärt. Ein schöner Kanal, Brexit Explained.
Und wer Bock hat, mal so full in zu gehen, dem empfehle ich mal das Nachhören
von einem Videopodcast, der ist sehr unterhaltsam, Three Blokes in a Pub.
Also so drei Typen in der Kneipe, wo ein Weltreisender,
einer der im Lkw-Transport-Business in ganz Europa unterwegs ist und ein Experte
beim Aushandeln von Trade-Deals weltweit,
der also aktiv sowas getan hat,
mal so richtig schön ablassen, was eigentlich die Realität ist.
Und es ist sehr unterhaltsam, aber auch mega erschreckend, was da sozusagen alles bei rauskommt.
Also da sieht man mal, hier wird leider die Öffentlichkeit komplett hinters
Licht geführt und man kann nur hoffen, dass es in Großbritannien noch eine Art
Umsturz gibt, weil sonst haben wir echt ein richtiges Problem.
Ein Bild dazu Sonst haben wir ja keine Probleme,
also weltweit das Thema was wir heute gar nicht ansprechen wollen ist US Supreme
Court Benennung von Brett Kavanaugh ein neuer Tiefpunkt,
von allem nach den ganzen anderen letzten neuen Tiefpunkten sondern Sondern
wir kümmern uns jetzt um den Alarm, denn, wie die Blödzeitung uns informiert,
Deutschlands Cybersheriff schlägt Alarm.
Alarm, Alarm.
Alljährlich kommt der BSI-Lagebericht raus.
Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik informiert dann da über
eben die Cyberlage in Deutschland und es ist natürlich unschwer vorherzusagen,
die Situation ist ernst und der Cybersheriff Arne Schönbohm schlägt Alarm.
Jetzt hatte ich mir den Genuss, mir diesen BSI-Lagerbericht mal ein bisschen
im Detail anzuschauen und jetzt
muss man natürlich sagen, 2017 war kein besonders gutes Jahr für das BSI.
Was ist passiert 2017?
Bundesregierung wurde gehackt. Wir erinnern uns an diese Webseite der Hochschule des Bundes,
die dann genutzt wurde, um damit Schadsoftware an Mitarbeiter des Auswärtigen Amtes auszuliefern.
Und die wurden dann nur durch Zufall, weil einer dieser Mitarbeiter mit dem
Laptop in ein anderes Netz gegangen ist, entdeckt, dass dort eben Traffic zu,
wie man glaube ich damals vermutete,
der Hackergruppe APT28 ausgeleitet wurde.
Und quasi nur, weil dieser Mitarbeiter des Auswärtigen Amtes einen Laptop hatte
und dann eben beim Verteidigungsministerium irgendwie zu Besuch war und beim
Verteidigungsministerium andere Detektionsregeln auf der Firewall waren,
als an anderer Stelle ist dieser Fall aufgefallen.
Warum ist das schlecht fürs BSI?
Naja, der Schutz genau dieser Regierungsnetze des IVBB, des Informationsverbundes
Berlin-Brandenburg, das ist genau die Aufgabe des BSI.
Das ist deren, das fällt in deren Verantwortung.
In der Berichterstattung hieß es immer, ja das Netz ist sicher, das Netz ist sicher.
Hacker hacken halt auch keine Netze, sondern die hacken Endpunkte.
Das Netz ist in der Regel relativ egal.
Das Netz ist, könnte man quasi sagen, auch sicher geblieben.
Liest man jetzt aber den BSI-Lagebericht, dann findet man da sowas wie,
gegen Ende des Jahres 2017 hat das BSI über das nationale Cyberabwehrzentrum
Hinweise auf einen erfolgreichen Cyberangriff erhalten,
von dem einzelne Bundesbehörden betroffen sein sollten. Das ist echt schön.
Damit hatten die ja überhaupt nichts zu tun. Über das Cyberabwehrzentrum haben
wir da so einen Hinweis erhalten.
Dem sind wir natürlich nachgegangen. Wir starteten den Prozess der Vorfallsbearbeitung
in Abständung mit dem nationalen Cyberabwehrzentrum und so weiter.
Haben die potenziell betroffenen Behörden informiert und haben mit der Analyse
und der Verifikation der initial vorliegenden Informationen begonnen.
Und dann sagen sie, der Angriff erfolgte über einen Webster bei der Bundesakademie
für öffentliche Verwaltung.
Entschuldigung, ich hatte gerade irgendwie Bundeshochschule des Bundes oder
so, Hochschule des Bundes, nein, Bundesakademie für öffentliche Verwaltung.
Das BSI konnte den Cyberangriff auf das Auswärtige Abend durch den Einsatz eines
Mobile Incident Response Teams über längere Zeit beobachten und so tiefere Einsichten
in Absicht und Vorgehensweise der Täter erlangen,
größerer Schaden oder eine weitere
Ausbreitung konnten dank bestehender Schutzmaßnahmen verhindert werden.
Die berichten darüber so, als hätten sie damit überhaupt nichts zu tun gehabt
oder wären eher später zugerufen worden, obwohl das quasi genau ihr Problem ist.
Eine kleine Box und steht irgendwie so weiter nichts dazu.
Anderes Problem, was 2017 stattgefunden hat, ist natürlich die Bundestagswahl wurde gehackt.
Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtet, primär daran beteiligt eben Martin Schiersig,
Thorsten Schröder und ich die sich, wir haben jetzt ja ein paar Wochen mit dieser
Software auseinandergesetzt und eben wenige Wochen vor der Bundestagswahl.
Darüber berichtet und ich denke ich kann so viel aus den Hintergrundgesprächen
erzählen, dass da durchaus das Innenministerium und das BSI mit dieser Sachlage befasst waren.
Jetzt wurde bei der Pressekonferenz zur Vorstellung dieser ganzen Angelegenheit von einem,
Reporter, ich glaube der ARD, gefragt, sag mal, ich habe jetzt mal geguckt in
eurem Lagebericht 2017, da steht irgendwie gar nichts drin,
dass die Bundestagswahl 2017 gravierende Sicherheitslücken hatte,
die vom Chaos Computer Club untersucht und aufgedeckt wurden. Wie kann dat?
Seehofer war damals noch nicht im Minister.
Dann war noch die Frage nach den Gegenmaßnahmen.
Also wir hören auch hier, das BSI weist wieder seine,
Verantwortung von sich. Er sagt, das liegt ja in der Hoheit des Bundeswahlleiters
und ja, viel gibt es da nicht zu berichten. Ich meine,
Ich finde es wirklich sehr amüsant, wie wir hier, also zwei wirklich schwere
Katastrophen und das BSI geht noch nicht mal hin und erkennt da seine Verantwortung an.
Also man würde ja erwarten, dass sie sagen, ja okay, hier sind Defizite,
deswegen brauchen wir mehr Geld oder so.
Aber die gehen über beide Vorfälle so drüber hinweg, als wäre das irgendwie
geschehen und sie hätten damit nichts zu tun gehabt. Und das ist eigentlich
tatsächlich in dem gesamten BSI-Lagebericht so ein bisschen so,
du fragst dich, wofür haben wir das eigentlich?
Ja, die haben doch gesagt, wenn sie jetzt darüber reden, dann wissen ja die
Bösen, was zu tun ist, dann würden sie ja nur Tipps rausgeben.
Ja, BSI, Security by Obscurity, herzlichen Glückwunsch, geile Idee.
Also das ist doch wirklich, ich meine, ich finde das wirklich schwierig.
Ich habe das, glaube ich, hier auch schon öfter gesagt, der Vorgänger von Arne
Schönbohm, Herr Hanke, das war ja
jemand, mit dem hatte ich ja auch meine politischen Differenzen mal, ja.
Aber das war wenigstens jemand, der einen seriösen, verantwortungsbewussten
Umgang mit Fragen der IT-Sicherheit betrieben hat.
Und das sehe ich hier wirklich nicht.
Also wenn Vorfälle irgendwie unter den Teppich gekehrt werden,
gleichzeitig sie aber schaffen, dieses Cybersheriff schlägt Alarm,
überall sonst bricht die Welt zusammen, nur beim BSI ist alles in Ordnung.
Da haben sie eine wunderschöne Sache auch in ihrer Pressekonferenz dann eben
hervorgetan, wo sie also sagten, hier übrigens Steckenpferd des BSI, die Routerrichtlinie.
Die Routerrichtlinie. Ich hatte es schon ganz vergessen, dass ich mich damit
nämlich auch 2017 und 2018 auseinandergesetzt habe.
Und zwar bezieht sich das auf 2016 hatten wir den Ausfall der Telekom-Router,
also die einige erinnern sich vielleicht, damals sind knapp 900.000 Telekom-Router ausgefallen.
Weil sie eine Availability Schwachstelle hatten, also sie konnten leicht,
sind einem DDoS einem DOS zum Opfer gefallen, DDoS kann man da kaum zu sagen
das waren irgendwie sieben Pakete, die die brauchten, um abzuschmieren Also Denial of Service.
Genau, also die Router sind ausgefallen, weil es im Rahmen eines anderen Angriffs,
für den sie nicht verwundbar waren, zu einem erhöhten Aufkommen bestimmter Pakete kam.
Und diese Sache, diesen Ausfall, der ja jetzt nicht, der war ja keine Kleinigkeit,
annähernd eine Million Internetanschlüsse in Deutschland fallen aus.
Gut, die meisten haben es gar nicht gemerkt, weil Netz eh scheiße ist in Deutschland,
aber das war natürlich etwas, da ist auch sofort Innenministerium und Wirtschaftsministerium
sind da sofort darauf aufmerksam geworden und haben, glaube ich,
sehr zügig die ersten Termine, die wir da hatten, waren,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche, im Januar 2017 oder so.
Oder vielleicht sogar noch Ende 2016. Da gab es mehrere Anhörungen zu öffentliche
und nicht öffentliche, wo ich auch als Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs damals
war und dann eben diese Anhörungen,
diese Idee, dass das BSI jetzt eine Richtlinie verfasst, wie es um Router zu
bestehen hat, damit da irgendwie so etwas nicht mehr passiert.
Wie gesagt, fing damals an im Wirtschaftsministerium, dann ging es weiter im
Innenministerium, weil es eben am Ende eine BSI-Sache ist.
Da hatten wir, ich glaube sowas wie irgendwas zwischen drei und fünf Terminen.
Ich bin da ein paar mal hingegangen, Frank Rieger ist da hingegangen und Mirko
Vogt vom Chaos Computer Club und Freifunk ist da hingegangen.
Wir haben diesen Prozess so ein bisschen begleitet.
Das ist ganz geil. Da sitzt du dann mit irgendwie 30, 40 Leuten.
Die Leute sind Stakeholder, also Hersteller von solchen Geräten,
Betreiber von Netzen und dann irgendwie CCC.
Ich glaube, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, bei ein oder zwei Treffen war auch Klaus Landefeld.
Also vom DZX, die betroffenen Organisationen, mal wieder natürlich nur so Gesamtverband
der Versicherungswirtschaft,
habe ich da auch mal jemanden gesehen, also auch so ein paar, wo man sagen würde,
okay, die haben hier unabhängiges Interesse,
Chaos Computer Club, würde ich mal so sagen, wir sind da hingekommen,
um eben technisch beratend zu stehen.
Wir hatten natürlich unsere Forderungen.
Unsere Forderungen waren primär, bitte, bitte, bitte Haftung einführen.
Das ist ja das, was wir immer sagen. Wir wollen für bestimmte Fälle,
in denen eben Fahrlässigkeit nachzuweisen ist, wollen wir Haftung der Hersteller.
Weil über Haftung klären sich sehr viele Details sehr schnell.
Und automatisch.
Da schafft man einfach einen Anreiz und dann klappt das.
Wenn du keine Haftung hast, wie zum Beispiel jetzt bei der Manipulation von
Dieselsteuergeräten oder so, dann merkst du, dass sich der Markt sehr langsam
erst anpasst an die Anforderungen, die du haben möchtest. Deswegen haben wir
gesagt, hier mach doch einfach einen Preisschnitt dran.
Was meinst du, wie schnell solche Sachen passieren?
Weiterer Punkt natürlich eine unserer Forderungen, eine Verpflichtung Updates
bereitzustellen für einen genannten Mindestzeitraum,
den wir eben auch quasi diktiert haben wollen durch diese Anforderungen.
Und dann, sehr, sehr wichtig, eine unserer zentralen Forderungen,
auch wenn du jetzt als Hersteller sagst, für dieses Gerät leiste ich keinen
Support mehr, das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, acht Jahre alt.
Wir haben dafür jetzt Software-Updates bereitgestellt über die letzten acht Jahre.
Nun hören wir damit auf. Was ist dann?
Das ist ein sehr interessanter Fall, weil dann ja im Prinzip die Nutzerinnen
dieser Geräte vor der Entscheidung stehen, okay,
gehe ich das Risiko jetzt ein, dieses Gerät weiterhin zu betreiben,
welches unter Umständen unsicher ist oder werfe ich es jetzt weg?
Weil wer weiß, wie lange das noch sicher bzw. unsicher ist.
Die dritte Option wäre natürlich zu sagen, okay, wenn der Hersteller schon sagt,
wir kümmern uns jetzt nicht mehr um die Software,
dann wäre natürlich eigentlich zu erwarten, dass der Hersteller sagt,
wenn wir es nicht machen, dann
kannst du lieber Verbraucher oder liebe Verbraucherin das selber machen.
Und oder eine Open Source Community möge sich bitte dieses Gerätes bemächtigen.
Sehr viele ältere WLAN-Router kannst du ja sehr gut betreiben,
zum Beispiel mit OpenWRT, mit einer quelloffenen, wunderbaren,
freien Software, die mit einer aktiven Entwickler-Community diese Geräte weiterführen kann.
Also das war unser Verlangen, dass man sagt, wenn du aufwärst,
dich darum zu kümmern, dann sei verpflichtet, das freizugeben.
Im Prinzip eine rein ökologische Forderung, zu sagen, okay,
wenn du dieses Gerät in einen Zustand versetzt oder das Risiko eingestellt,
dass dieses Gerät nicht mehr sicher betrieben werden kann,
dann wäre eigentlich die notwendige Konsequenz, die Menschen müssen es wegwerfen
und das ist ein elektronisches Gerät, was,
wenn es noch funktioniert, mit einer anderen Software, vielleicht auch funktionieren kann.
Wenn du deiner Verantwortung nicht mehr gerecht werden möchtest,
der Nachsorge, dann musst du es wenigstens anderen ermöglichen.
Wäre sowas wie, um jetzt mal bei dem Autovergleich zu bleiben,
stell dir mal vor, VW würde dir ein Auto verkaufen und sagen,
also unsere Werkstätten liefern dir dafür für die nächsten zehn Jahre Ersatzteile
und reparieren das, aber dann endet leider dein Supportvertrag.
Wenn die Karre dann kaputt ist, dann hast du eben Pech gehabt.
Aber in eine freie Werkstatt darfst du nicht gehen. Das möchten wir verhindern.
Würdest du nicht akzeptieren. Also das waren unsere Forderungen,
die wir da an den Tisch gebracht haben.
Immer vor dem Hintergrund.
Das ist die zentrale Forderung. Wie schaffen wir es denn, dass zumindest deutschlandweit,
was ja schon der geringste Anspruch ist,
eigentlich möchtest du ja ein Sicherheitsniveau mindestens europaweit oder gar weltweit anheben, ja?
Wie können wir das denn da durchsetzen? So, da fanden dann diese Treffen statt.
Wir hatten dann Vertreter, der Netzbetreiber, Vertreter der Gerätehersteller
und dann wurde da diskutiert, was denn jetzt mal so eine Sicherheitsanforderung wäre.
Dann wurde gesagt, ja, wir könnten ja zum Beispiel reinschreiben,
dass das Passwort bei der Inbetriebnahme geändert werden muss oder so.
Oder dass es keine Standardpasswörter gibt.
Ah, das ist aber schwierig. Und dann wird da so drüber diskutiert und wenn die
Anforderung zu hart wurde, Dann haben die Hersteller gequengelt und wenn zum
Beispiel die Anforderung war, okay, wir wollen eine Open-Source-Software darauf haben,
dann haben sich hier die Kabelnetzbetreiber gequengelt, weil die ja effektiv
einen Routerzwang durchsetzen.
Ja, die versuchen dir genau das zu verbieten, eigene Open Source Software und
so weiter da zu betreiben.
Naja und so wird ja dann lange darüber diskutiert und jetzt hast du zwei Jahre
nach dem Vorfall soll also jetzt diese Richtlinie veröffentlicht werden und
jetzt kommt das Schöne, diese Richtlinie ist vollständig freiwillig.
Die ist erstmal allenfalls das Papierwert, auf dem du das PDF ausdruckst,
denn sie hat null Verbindlichkeit. Die steht erstmal nur da.
Also das BSI kann Richtlinien schreiben, wie es will, die haben dann eine Nummer
und dann kannst du halt sagen, okay, hier nach Richtlinie so und so.
Das ist aber jetzt nicht, dass sie, also alles, was darauf noch aufbauen würde,
zum Beispiel jetzt eine Zertifizierung nach dieser Richtlinie oder ein Gütesiegel
oder eine Verbindlichkeit dieser Richtlinie für den Eintritt in irgendeinen
Markt, das passiert erstmal alles nicht.
Das ist das Ergebnis nach zwei Jahren. Ja, eine zerwässerte Richtlinie.
Jetzt freut sich der Arne Schönbohm und sagt, ja, also der nächste Schritt wird
dann nämlich sein, dann haben wir ein Gütesiegel.
Dann haben wir ein Gütesiegel. Meine Güte. Dann stehst du im Mediamarkt und
dann hast du so ein schönes Deutschland-Siegel, wie der Arne Schönbohm ja auch
hier immer am Anorak hat, links.
Der hat immer so eine kleine Deutschland-Fahne, Cyber-Schland oder sowas.
So und so,
dann hast du ein Gütesiegel und das war sehr schön ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wer das damals.
Von wem damals dieser Satz kam in diesem Treffen im Innenministerium,
weil dann nämlich gesagt wurde ja, weil Gütesiegel, wenn es nämlich dann ein
Gütesiegel gibt, dann kann der Verbraucher seine Risikoabwägung selber treffen.
Und dann meldet sich jemand und sagt, der Verbraucher, der in den Mediamarkt
geht, der hat seine Risikoabwägung bereits getroffen.
Und was immer, immer das große Ding war, die haben natürlich dann gebashed,
also die Hersteller deutscher Geräte haben dann immer gesagt,
ja und der ganze China-Schrott, der ganze China-Schrott.
Von dem sie sich gerne absetzen wollten und dafür wollten sie gerne dieses Siegel
haben, weil die Weil die deutschen Hersteller sich dann eben wünschen,
ja, dann können wir sagen, wir haben hier so ein BSI-Gütesiegel auf unseren
Geräten und dann können wir nämlich unsere höheren Preise rechtfertigen.
Um nichts anderes ging es da.
Da hat kein Mensch noch das Ziel vor Augen gehabt, dass man ernsthaft ein...
Sich in eine Richtung bewegt, wo man wirklich in Deutschland mal nachhaltig
aus diesem Problem lernen würde.
Zwei Jahre ist da gar nichts passiert und jetzt haben wir eine unverbindliche
Richtlinie. Das wird noch Jahre dauern, bis die umgesetzt ist.
Und genau zum Beispiel für sowas wie lange es noch Software-Updates gibt,
ist in dieser Richtlinie nicht definiert.
Es ist nur definiert, dass du das ansagen musst.
Es ist wieder so ein richtig schönes Wischi-Waschi. Schreibst du hin,
Wie lange gibt es noch Sicherheitsupdates?
Drei Tage, dann erfüllst du quasi die Richtlinie.
Also es ist wirklich zum Heulen und man würde sich tatsächlich wünschen,
dass hier dieses BSI mal wirklich auch die Kraft bekommen würde und den Mut
und auch das Backing vom Innenministerium, von der Bundesregierung mal wirklich
durchgreifen zu können.
Ja, und dieser Bereich der Router,
TR-Router, technische Richtlinie Router ist ja nur einer, wo ich dann eben sehe,
wie sowas über die Jahre zerredet wird und am Ende so ein Papiertiger dabei
rauskommt, der vollständig zahnlos ist.
Das ist wirklich traurig, finde ich wirklich traurig.
Insofern, ich bin da wirklich nicht sehr zufrieden mit der Arbeit des BSI.
Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, das BSI ist eine wichtige Einrichtung und wir können
eigentlich froh sein, so etwas zu haben und es wäre halt toll,
wenn wir da auch ein bisschen was von hätten als Bürgerinnen und Bürger des
Landes und da mal wirklich in Deutschland auch mal jenseits von D-Mail,
PC-Wahl,
BEA und all diesen ganzen Wenn.
Mal irgendwas richtig funktionieren würde.
Eine Sache.
Ein einziges Ding, was mal irgendwie okay wäre, wo man sagt.
Und es ist immer so, ja das können wir jetzt nicht machen, wir können jetzt
die Hersteller zwingen.
Weißt du, wenn die das von alleine machen, wenn die sich ihre Richtlinie selber
schreiben, danach wie sie die erfüllen können,
dann kannst Lass sie dir das sparen, dann brauchst du das nicht zu machen,
so während dieses Ding da zerredet wird, ne.
Macht so ein WhatsApp, während wir die D-Mail philosophieren,
ja, macht so ein WhatsApp einfach mal ein Upgrade und hat Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung, ja.
Ich will jetzt wirklich nicht WhatsApp loben und wirklich nicht Facebook,
aber irgendwie, es wäre schon gut, so eine IT-Sicherheitspolitik zu betreiben,
wo am Ende auch mal was passiert.
Ja, aber man hat immer noch nicht E-Mail im Griff von Porn.
Wir haben aber mehrere Anläufe unternommen. Also ich war gestern in Oldenburg
an dem Institut für Informatik da, haben wir mit so ein paar Leuten drüber gesprochen.
Weißt du, wie viele, also wir haben irgendwie diese,
Volksverschlüsselung, wir haben das D-Mail, wir haben den E-Postbrief,
wir haben das besondere elektronische Anwaltspostfach und mir sind noch zwei
weitere Sachen eingefallen, wo in Millionen,
Projekten versucht wurde, irgendwie das E-Mail sicher zu machen.
Ich frage mich, wann das nächste kommt, weil es längere Zeit nichts mehr passiert.
Das ist nicht unglaublich. Und das, obwohl es, wie wir auch schon mehrfach betont
haben, eigentlich ja schon lange was gibt.
Das Problem ist seit Jahrzehnten.
Es gibt es schon alles. High-S-Mime könnte man einfach einführen.
Dafür habt ihr irgendwie euren elektronischen Personalausweis und all diesen Kram.
Das wäre alles da gewesen für eine Mark 80.
Wenn das nix kostet, dann ist das auch nix.
Das ist wirklich ne Katastrophe das ist wirklich ich find das ganz schlimm du
merkst auch, dass die Leute alle in diesen Treffen sitzen da kam ja beim dritten
Mal kein Techie mehr hin, der einzige Techie der da noch hingegangen ist,
war Mirko und der kam auch jedes Mal irgendwie so Zähneknirschen zurück und
sagte so Linus, was hast du ich möchte das nicht,
weil der irgendwie die ganze Zeit nur so Marketing-Heinis sitzen,
die irgendwie ihre drei Notizen haben und sagen, wenn das und das gesagt wird, sagen nein.
Da kommen noch die friedliebsten Nerds und wir anderen wollen nur noch töten.
Ich würde dem Mirko jetzt nicht unterstellen, dass er töten wollte,
aber er war jetzt nicht mal weit weg davon.
Schlimm. Und da werden wir auch wieder zerrieben.
Next. Kommen wir zu einem schönen jetzt kommen wir zu einem schönen Thema,
das ihr in der letzten Sendung schon angesprochen hattet.
Bloomberg. Bloomberg hat mal wieder einen Scoop gehabt. Wahnsinn-Story.
Richtig geile Recherche.
Story geht so, es gibt einen Hersteller von Mainboards, primär im Serverbereich.
Das ist ein US-amerikanischer Hersteller, trägt den Namen Supermicro.
Also so US-Taiwanesisch. Ja, okay.
Und produziert, wie eigentlich alle, seine Hardware in China.
Und hat es jetzt so im Serverbereich, glaube ich, sehr, sehr verbreitet.
Und jetzt sagt Bloomberg, ja, also es wäre so gewesen, bei Amazon waren eben
Supermicro, nee, Amazon wollte ein Unternehmen kaufen,
dieses Unternehmen hatte in seinen Servern Supermicro-Boards im Einsatz und
dann hat Amazon im Rahmen seiner Akquisitionsüberlegungen gesagt,
hier, wir schicken da mal ein paar Pentester durch.
Und die haben dann Hardware-Trojaner auf diesen Boards gefunden, auf den Mainboards.
Kleine Chips, die quasi nicht in den Bestellungen von Supermicro drin waren.
Die auf diesen Boards saßen und so wird beschrieben, die irgendwie irgendeine
Form von Eigenleben entwickelt haben was hier jetzt technisch nicht genauer beschrieben wird.
Und irgendwie aber die ganzen Computer trojanisiert haben und dann dachte ich
so Wahnsinn, so unglaubliche Geschichte,
fast wie die NSA das bei anderen Leuten macht der Aktienkurs von Supermicro
ging irgendwie ab in den Keller,
die haben irgendwie sowas wie 50% Börsenwert verloren an dem gleichen Tag und
alle Stakeholder in der ganzen Angelegenheit widersprechen heftigst, Supermicro,
Amazon und Apple, die auch Supermicrobots irgendwo für ihre iCloud oder sowas
im Einsatz haben, ich glaube, war gar nicht genau spezifiziert wo.
Apple und Amazon widersprechen der Geschichte sogar gegenüber dem Kongress und
sagen offiziell, also das, was da steht, das gibt's nicht.
Und Bloomberg sagt aber, wir haben mit 17 Quellen gesprochen,
die wir hier nicht namentlich nennen können.
Die Story stimmt, das ist ein ganz klarer Fall.
Dann geht Patrick Gray hin vom Risky Business Podcast und spricht mit einer
der wenigen namentlich benannten Quellen in diesem Artikel und sagt nochmal
hier was du bist da namentlich genannt, wie siehst du denn diesen Artikel?
Also Joe Fitzpatrick, der so auf Blackhead und so weiter öfter schon mal Präsentationen
gemacht hat, so wie könnte man denn das theoretisch machen?
Genau, Hardware-Trojaner sind quasi seine, sein Forschungsbereich relativ einfach,
der guckt sich Geräte an, in diesem Fall eben auch den,
SPI-Bus auf Boards und sowas und hat gesagt, wenn man da einen kleinen Chip
drauf machen würde, der folgendes könnte, weil es eben ein Bus ist,
da sind ja dann alle Informationen drauf und jetzt, das wäre ja total,
da könnte man ja Hardware-Trojaner bauen.
Und der hat gesagt, er hätte genau so wären auch seine Gespräche mit Bloomberg
gewesen, dass die Bloomberg-Leute ihn gefragt haben, wenn man hier einen,
wenn man so einen kleinen Chip auf so einem Board hätte, was könnte man denn damit alles machen?
Und er hat dann denen erklärt, ja, da könntest du, was weiß ich,
einen Ethernet-Konnektor simulieren und du könntest irgendwie den ganzen Rechner
übernehmen und zum Beispiel folgendes tun.
Und in der Bloomberg-Geschichte steht, so schildert er, alles,
was er so gesagt hat, was passieren könnte, steht in dem Bloomberg-Artikel als
gegebene Tatsache durch diesen kleinen Chip.
Und dummerweise findet sich, sagt selbst Bloomberg nicht, hier gibt es mal so
ein Chip und man würde jetzt davon ausgehen, dass vielleicht ein paar Leute,
die Supermicrobots in ihrem Keller haben, mal runtergehen und gucken,
ob sich da vielleicht so ein Chip drauf befinden könnte oder so.
Niemand findet etwas, niemand kann diese Geschichte in irgendeiner Form bestätigen.
Das Lustige ist, das einzige Bild, was hier sozusagen als Beispielchip mit sowas
könnte es sein, abbilden, ist ein Bild, was dieser Joe ihm auf Nachfrage geschickt
hat, so naja, wir haben gehört, das ist so ein Übertrager, wie sieht denn sowas aus?
Und dann hat er aus irgendeinem Katalog so ein Bild rausgenommen und genau dieses
Bild, was er ihm geschickt hat, landet dann in diesem Artikel sozusagen und er meinte so,
sowas baut man nicht auf dem Mainboard, sowas baut man vielleicht auf eine Internetkarte
oder so weiter, wo man so Transziver dran hat, aber wenn sowas auf dem Mainboard
ist, dann sagt jeder, der irgendwie was von Hardware versteht,
Da steht so, hä, was ist denn das?
So, ja, was hat das da überhaupt zu suchen? Also nicht sonderlich gut versteckt.
Also als nächstes findet, wo du gerade sagst, was braucht man auf dem Network-Interface?
Als nächstes findet Bloomberg dann einen israelischen Unternehmer,
der gesagt, er hätte bei einem Pentest bei einem Telekom-Anbieter auf Supermicroboards
auf dem Netzwerkkarte-Hardware-Trojaner gefunden.
Bloomberg sagt, ja hier, wir haben einen weiteren Zeugen. Komplett andere Geschichte,
nämlich nicht mehr das Board, sondern das Network Interface betroffen.
Und dieser Typ hat ein Unternehmen, was genau sagt, es würde Hardware-Trojaner lösen.
Er hat irgendwie so ein komisches... und verkauft dagegen irgendwelche Schlangenöl.
Und du findest wieder nur Dementis dieser ganzen Story.
Keiner will da jemals was von gehört haben. Fazit bisher, die Geschichte ist
trotzdem jetzt so generell möglich und glaubwürdig,
ja, aber die Art, wie sie berichtet wird, ohne jeglichen Beleg,
alle widersprechen, niemand sagt, okay, hier, gib doch mal so ein Chip, zeig doch mal, ne?
Ja, auch die Art, wie es dementiert wird. Das ist ja nicht nur so,
dass man jetzt so shady Dementis hat mit, ja, wir können uns dazu nicht äußern
oder so, sondern sagen alle so, nee, kennen wir nicht, hatten wir nicht,
wir haben alle gefragt, wir haben hier eine Investigation gestartet, nee,
nichts von gehört, weiß keiner was zu, es gibt ja auch keine FBI Investigation,
wir haben mit niemandem zusammengearbeitet.
Alles Sachen, die ja dann von dritter Stelle auch schnell belegbar wären oder
widerlegbar wären und von daher scheint an dieser ganzen Geschichte herzlich
wenig dran zu sein, sodass man sich fragt, wo kommt es denn eigentlich her,
wenn es denn da so viele Quellen gibt angeblich.
Tja, darüber wird jetzt spekuliert. Ich bin einfach mal sehr gespannt.
Also Bloomberg steht ja natürlich auch mit einem halbwegs guten Namen in der Kreide.
Und das ist halt eine Nummer zu groß, um sowas irgendwie bei sowas Unsinn zu behaupten.
Es ist immer noch möglich, dass Bloomberg morgen irgendwie das Ding aus der
Tasche holt und sagt, hier ist der Hardware-Trojaner, hier sind fünf unabhängige
Gutachter, die das genau beschreiben, dass alles so ist, wie wir es sagen,
aber bis jetzt riecht das nicht danach und ich habe den, es nähert sich langsam die Befürchtung.
Dass diese Journalisten hier irgendwie ein bisschen die.
Standard ihrer Arbeit verletzen. Einer des Informationskampagnen auch vor allem
auf den Leim gegangen sind.
Das kann natürlich auch sein. Es passt ja zu der Storyline des Pentagon und
vor allem der Planung von Donald Trump, dass jetzt diese ganze Produziererei
in China passt jetzt politisch nicht so ganz.
Ja, das wird schlecht geredet. Es wird ja hier auch auf Future Zone von Erich
Möchel ein wenig nahegelegt, dass das einfach jetzt die Quellen sind.
Hier wird einfach behauptet, China ist gefährlich für die Produktion,
lass mal lieber in den USA machen.
Was im Übrigen, wie jeder weiß, der wenig Einblick hat in diese Industrien,
derzeit einfach vollkommen illusorisch ist.
Es ist derzeit einfach niemand in der Lage, auch nur annähernd diese Produktionskapazitäten,
geschweige denn die Preise, die China da derzeit realisiert und Taiwan,
auch nur annähernd im Westen zu reproduzieren, geschweige denn zu unterbieten
und von daher ist das alles Wunschdenken.
Gut, kommen wir zu neuen künstlichen Intelligenzgeschichten.
Dadurch wird ja alles besser, haben wir gelernt.
Ja, künstliche Intelligenz ist ja super klug.
Die alte Intelligenz war nicht so geil. Jetzt nehmen wir die künstliche.
Und da hat Amazon, oder willst du das erzählen?
Ich kann das kurz erzählen. Also Amazon hat sich gedacht, naja,
Recruiting ist ja voll anstrengend. Wir brauchen jetzt so viele neue Leute.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal mit Software optimieren. Und hat dafür ein Team in Edinburgh gestartet.
Die haben dann 2014 angefangen, so eine Software zu entwickeln.
Und die wollte dann sozusagen die Bewerbungen des potenziellen neuen Personals
einfach sich durchlesen und bewerten auf Basis von, naja, früheren Bewerbungen.
Und haben da irgendwelche Modelle sich gebaut für Jobfunktionen,
um das alles zu bewerten und so gut 50.000 Begriffe in den Bewerbungen ausgewertet,
um dann am Ende für jeden Bewerber so ein bis fünf Sterne,
zu vergeben, um zu sehen wie geil denn das so ist,
Wäre eh so ein Freund von Sternchen für Bewertungen mit Fünf-Sterne-System ist schön doof.
Fünf-Sterne-Deluxe.
Ja. Kannst du diesen schönen Witz? My Review of the Solar System? One Star.
Naja, auf jeden Fall stellte sich 2015 schnell raus. Klappt alles nicht so wie gedacht.
Die Datenbasis war nämlich die Bewerbung der letzten zehn Jahre und das waren
im Wesentlichen Männer.
Und stellt sich raus, hat alles nicht so gut funktioniert, weil unter anderem
Worte, die Männer gerne verwenden, höher bewertet wurden und auch so diverse
Abstufungen vorgenommen wurden, wenn halt irgendwas mit Frauen da drin stand.
Also wenn irgendeine Frau gesagt hat, sie war so in ihrem Schachclub irgendwie,
Captain, dann führte das in diesem Algorithmus eben zur Abwertung.
Und wir wissen ja bei AI und Machine Learning Sachen, man weiß immer,
also da wird nicht ein Algorithmus gemacht, sondern der Algorithmus ergibt sich
aus den Daten, mit denen man die Maschine füttert.
Deswegen kann man das alles erst im Nachhinein feststellen. Da wurde dann auch
noch manuell nachbearbeitet und so eine Sachen versucht auszugleichen.
Auch so, dass irgendwie, wenn Frauen auf einem College waren,
wo nur Frauen waren, dann führte das auch zur Abwertung.
Einfach dadurch, dass man die falschen Daten hatte.
Und es blieb einfach am Ende auch noch genug Quatsch über. Funktionierte alles nicht.
Es wurden einfach nur noch Unqualifizierte für irgendwelche Jobs vorgeschlagen
und 2017 wurde dieses Programm eingestellt und angeblich hätten sie es ja auch
nie so richtig zum Einsatz gebracht.
Was man hier sieht, also,
Ein klassisches Problem bei der Anwendung von künstlicher Intelligenz ist,
dass das Ding eben aus Daten der Vergangenheit gefüttert werden muss.
Das kann nur so gut werden, wie die Recruiter vorher waren.
Und wenn du eben, wenn du in deinen Lerndaten diesen Bias hast zu männlichen Bewerbern,
dann ist das ganz selbstverständlich, dass deine AI das auch lernt.
Ja, das fängt auch, selbst wenn man das Wort Female jetzt da rausgenommen hätte,
dann wird es das eben an anderen Sachen festmachen, was weiß ich irgendwie,
Dauer der Ausbildung oder es gibt viele Unterschiede.
Es waren auch so Wörter, die Männer gerne benutzen, so executed.
Oder die spielen eben Football statt Soccer in den USA.
Also es ist ganz klar, das wird passieren, wenn du Biases hast,
wird deine AI die auch reproduzieren.
Es sei denn, du sorgst dafür, dass du dem Ding ausreichend Futter gibst,
dass es das Gegenteil lernen kann.
Das war übrigens auch genau das, was ich damals bei dem Einsatz zu Risikomanagement-Systemen
in der Besteuerung an den Bundestag gemeldet habe, dass ich gesagt habe,
wenn ihr so einen Mist einsetzt, müsst ihr mindestens 50% der Entscheidungen
auch nochmal auf Basis von Zufall treffen,
damit das Ding überhaupt Gelegenheit bekommt, seine eigenen Voraussagen wieder zu revidieren.
Weil wenn das Ding jetzt einmal anfängt, Männer zu bevorteilen,
dann kann es nicht mehr feststellen.
Dass Frauen unter Umständen besser sind. Es fängt dann nur noch an,
zwischen Männern zu diskriminieren.
Und das ist jetzt nur das eine, was du halt feststellst, dass es irgendwie sagt,
ah, zwischen Männern und Frauen.
Das kann aber nochmal genauso gut bei den Männern nochmal nach der sozialen
Herkunft oder sonstigen Unterschieden haben.
Und das Üble ist eben teilweise auch, wenn das einfach nicht explizit in den
Daten ist, sondern nur implizit.
Deswegen macht man sowas nicht und es wäre auch echt sehr schön,
wenn dieser AI-Hype da irgendwann mal zum Ende kommen würde und Leute das irgendwie
vernünftig zur Anwendung bringen würden.
Gerade bei Amazon würde es ja eigentlich hoffen, dass da genug Leute sind,
die sich wenigstens bei dem Einsatz dieser Technologien irgendwie der Fallstricke bewusst sind.
Kommen wir zurück in den Bundestag. Wir haben ja jetzt die AfD dort sitzen und
die AfD hat Geld und Zeit, denn wirklich arbeiten braucht sie ja nicht.
Wir erinnern uns, wie der Gauleiter im Sommerinterview auch nochmal erzählt
hat, was alles nicht seine Aufgabe ist.
Wohl aber natürlich das Stellen von Anträgen.
Und am heutigen Freitag wird dann sehr schön im Bundestag im Zweifelsfall ohne
Diskussion entschieden.
Der Antrag zum Entzug der Finanzierung.
Für die Netzkonferenz Republika. Antrag der Abgeordneten Jan-Ralf Nolte,
Marc Bernhard, Joanna Eleonora Cotar, Ach jetzt, Siegbert Dröse, Franziska Gminder,
Elsner von Gronow, Jens Kästner, Jern König, Rüdiger Lukassen,
Christoph Neumann, Bernhard Ulrich Oehme, Gerold Otten, René Springer und der Fraktion der AfD.
Den man sieht, die brauchen echt eine ganze Menge Leute, um da irgendwie zwei Seiten zu schreiben.
Wo sie eben sagen, ja, weil die Republika sich hier gegen die Soldaten gewendet hat.
Das dürfte, sollte sie also jetzt keine Förderung mehr in der Zukunft erhalten.
Stimmt natürlich überhaupt nicht. Die Republika hat überhaupt keine Soldaten ausgeschlossen.
Die Republika hat einfach nur gesagt, wir möchten bitte, dass sie keine Uniform
tragen und wir können ihnen, wenn sie da Uniform tragen, eben auch keinen Stand anbieten.
Ja, gegen Geld.
Ja, also das Geld, da wäre ja auch wieder eine staatliche Förderung der Republika quasi.
Nein, das wäre diese Bundeswehr Arbeitgebermarke gewesen, die das bezahlt hätte.
Und da sehen wir eben, was für Leute wir da jetzt haben.
Jetzt greifen sie, und das war ja auch die ganze Zeit klar,
also im Prinzip sind sie ja hier im Fahrwasser von Peter Tauber,
von der CDU, der damit ja angefangen hat, zu sagen, ey, was ist das hier,
die kriegen öffentliche Mittel, jetzt müssen wir die angreifen.
AfD ist da natürlich gerne mit dabei.
Außerdem gibt es eine sehr schöne kleine Anfrage der AfD-Fraktion,
wo sie von der Bundesregierung wissen möchten,
Welche Programme von NGO sie in welcher Höhe finanziell unterstützt hat.
Und da interessieren sie sich für Ärzte ohne Grenzen, die Amadeo Antonio Stiftung,
Amnesty International, die Clinton Foundation,
Korrektiv, das European Center for Press and Media Freedom,
European Civil Liberties Union, European Council on Foreign Relations,
European Stability Initiative, Global Investigative Journalism Network,
Human Rights Watch. Ich bin hier.
Internationale Organisation für Migration, Initiative Transparente Zivilgesellschaft,
Investigative Europe, Journalismfund.eu, Journalists Network,
Jugend rettet, Mediendienst Integration,
Migrant Offshore Aid Station, Mission Lifeline, Netzpolitik.org,
Netzwerk Recherche, No Border Network, Proactive Open Arms, Republika,
Reconquista, Internet.
Reporter ohne Grenzen, Save the Children, CIC Watch, SOS Mediterranee und Transparency International.
Arne Semsrott hat sehr gesagt, also im Prinzip so eine schöne Liste an Vorschlägen,
wo man Geld hinspenden kann, hat er lange nicht gesehen und dank dafür der AfD.
Aber wir Wir sehen sehr genau, dass jetzt eben deren Mitarbeiter und deren Abgeordnete
schon sehr klar anfangen,
ihre im Bundestag vorhandenen Einflussmöglichkeiten dazu zu nutzen,
jetzt gegen die offene Gesellschaft, gegen liberale Kräfte vorzugehen.
So, dann gibt es noch eine Meldung vom D-Kix.
Ich sage immer Zix, du sagst Kix.
Nee, ich sage Zix.
Du sagst auch Zix, dann sagen wir beide Zix. Wir sind ja hier auch die Netzpolitik-Zixen.
Wir erinnern uns, der D-Zix wehrt sich gegen die Anordnung, die er vom BND bekommt,
nämlich zur Ausleitung innerdeutscher Kommunikation am D-Zix in Frankfurt.
Und da hat er ja vor dem Bundesverwaltungsgericht gegen diese Anordnung klagen wollen.
Das wurde im Mai ohne weitere Verhandlungen abgewiesen, diese Beschwerde.
Und da wird eben gesagt, diese Entscheidung der Klageabweisung durch das Bundesverwaltungsgericht
ohne jegliche inhaltliche Prüfung der Klage überhaupt, können wir uns so nicht bieten lassen.
Wir haben in der Klage umfassend vorgebrachte Verstöße dargelegt gegen das Briefpost-
und Fernmeldegeheimnis und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht behandelt die noch nicht einmal,
deswegen gehen wir vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht, um gegen die Entscheidung
des Bundesverwaltungsgerichts sich damit nicht zu befassen zu klagen.
Können wir dem TZX natürlich nur viel Erfolg wünschen.
Das FBI hat dann jetzt auch den ersten Bruch der biometrischen Schutzmaßnahmen
an Geräten mal durchgezogen.
Und zwar ist es ja so, dass in den meisten zivilisierten Ländern Strafverfolgungsbehörden
nicht erzwingen können, dass man sein Passwort sagt.
Und so ein Graubereich juristisch war immer, wie ist das denn mit biometrischen
Merkmalen, hat das FBI jetzt einfach mal ausprobiert, ist bei einem eingeritten,
hat gesagt, hallo, Tag FBI,
Hausdurchsuchung und einmal hier bitte Face ID unlockt von dem Telefon.
Haben den quasi angewiesen, sein Gesicht vor das Gerät gehalten. Der hat es gemacht.
Und dann wurde er kurz darauf wegen Empfang und Besitz von dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs angeklagt.
Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie stehen wir dazu als Nutzer unter
Umständen dieser Technologie,
dass man dazu eben hier in dieser Form sich zwingen kann.
Ich würde hoffen, dass es da demnächst mal Urteile zu gibt.
Ja, wir hatten ja in der letzten Folge auch schon den Fall, dass Neuseeland
auch jetzt direkt nach Passwort anfragen darf.
Also da ist es nicht auf Biometrie beschränkt.
Und dann gibt es eine sehr schöne Meldung aus Frankreich.
Zwar wurde da ein Darknet-Marktplatz hochgenommen vor einiger Zeit durch den französischen Zoll.
Der hat den Namen Blackhand gehabt. Und die haben sich dann eben diesen Server
angeschaut und fanden heraus,
dass es dort jemanden gab, der sensible Daten und Informationen aus den nationalen
Polizeidatenbanken unter Pseudonym in diesem Darknet-Marktplatz verkauft hat.
Und zwar war das jemand, der für die Direktion Générale de la Sécurité interieur,
der DGSI, also den Inlandsgeheimdienst, gearbeitet hat und der soll sich eigentlich
um Terrorismus und Cybercrime kümmern und der hat jetzt irgendwie so gesagt,
ja für 300 Euro pro Auskunft könnte er bei mir Handynummern tracken oder die
Anruflisten aus den Vorratsdatenspeicherungen bekommen und er hat auch einen
Service beworben, wo man sich darüber informieren lassen konnte,
ob man von der Polizei gesucht wird oder was potenziell gegen einen vorliegt.
300 Euro finde ich echt einen guten Service, finde ich völlig in Ordnung.
Und da sieht man mal eben, was das bedeutet, wenn man diese Daten schafft.
Wenn du diese Daten schaffst, dann hast du eben darauf Zugriff und dieser Zugriff
kann eben auch missbräuchlich sein. und das passiert nicht nur in Frankreich.
Sondern potenziell überall.
Wir merken, dass ich ein bisschen kurz angebunden bin.
Und leider jetzt los muss. Deswegen machen wir ein kurzes schmerzloses Ende
mit einem Dankeschön, welches von mir geht an Alexander, Andreas, Arne,
Benedikt, Björn, Christian, Clemens, Daniel, Dirk, Fabian, Jens, Katharina,
Kai, Martin, Matthias, Michael, Peter, Ralf, Sebastian,
Simon, Steffen, Thomas, Tore, Tim, Tim und Judith, herzliche Grüße,
Tobias und Toni. Herzlichen Dank.
Man merkt, du warst eine Weile weg.
Und ja, wie man schon merkte, muss jetzt auch los.
Also machen wir erstmal Schluss. Wir haben noch ein paar Themen für die nächste Woche aufgespart.
Uns gehen die Themen ohnehin nicht aus.
Nee, leider nicht. Das wäre eigentlich schön. Eigentlich müsste man sagen, es wäre schön.
Erfolg hat dieser Podcast erst, wenn er nicht mehr nötig ist.
Ja. das Ziel dieses Podcasts ist nicht mehr nötig zu sein.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, bis bald Ciao, ciao.